they always tell you never to meet your  heroes because it's so disappointing and  that's usually true but 32 years ago  last month i met pg or work in a bar  in managua nicaragua he was a hero of  mine and he turned out to be every bit  the man i hoped he would be in for 30  years we were friends pg work a lot to  say about him just two things  one of the funniest people who ever  wrote in english at a time when you're  allowed to be funny which is to say  totally free and honest his 1987 book  republican party reptile still worth  reading his work for rolling stone in  the 70s  in the 80s nationally in pune in the 70s  remarkable  but he was also one of the very few  people in journalism who actually had a  happy life who cared about the right  things he loved his wife his children  northern new england his spaniels bird  hunting  having lunch with his friends tobacco  he was a man in full a great man it's  with deep sadness we tell you that he  passed away today at 74.